good morning John there is a roast
yourself challenge happening right now
I've got some lyrics we're gonna do it
it's probably a bad idea yo what's up
Hank green here I roast myself like Ryan
Higa said give it all that I gotta give
I haven't even started very feeling
culturally appropriate Here I am sitting
where I sit every Thursday morning yeah
Thursday cuz I'm careful I'm normal I'm
boring I'm not gonna risk a punishment I
no longer have time for that I keep
adding to my list cuz I like it a hit
with baseball bats nah it's cuz I like
how it makes me feel like I matter cuz
I'm doing things even though it's not
real I want to be remembered but here's
what's pretty clear someday there will
be no humans ought to remember anybody
was here I need approval from society so
I do what it expects from you as a
straight Pale Male I can do it quite
expediently I sit in front of books so
that you know that I'm smart and while
my brother has natural buff I use the
stuff I got at Walmart majority of my
audience wants me to feel the bird but
I'm too old for revolution I just don't
want to feel it on a Trump okay
spending money has always given me
anxiety I avoid cursing because my
freedom is Trump's by propriety and I'll
never be like feuds on the cover of
variety and have a good audible brother
doesn't convey notoriety I keep talking
about a book that I'm gonna write
someday but it's never gonna be scipios
so why do I drag anywhere else nap chat
like a tween so let's do that instead
taking cat naps with my kill bar doing
it straight from my bed I'm 36 years old
I pretend to be a punk rocker but as
you've probably heard of a nerd who
sings mostly about Harry Potter and
thanks to a teleprompter I get to
pretend that I know everything about the
standard model and philosophy but mostly
I'm just reading so I pay people to do
the things and to help me create its
capitalist abyssus abyssum port but my
former self would hate ipon difficut
like I'm an expert but I'm really not
that great and yes if she asked I would
be Hillary's running mate but she's not
gonna cuz imma gangly white dude Rossa
myself on YouTube
I'm maybe a little old to be doing this
stuff maybe a little less silly in the
future
just chill it out a little bit I feel
like I feel like maybe focus on the
educational stuff not that like the fun
to hip rapping challenges I doesn't seem
like a good idea
nah thanks for bearing with me on that
one entire world not just the people who
watched everyone I apologize I don't
know why I was like hey let's do a song
challenge even have to do right now whoa
if you want to VidCon is coming up I try
not to talk too much about VidCon
because uh most people can go even
though it's really good time for the
first time ever this year thanks to a
sponsorship from YouTube we are going to
be able to livestream significant
portions of the event so yay people who
can't go at least no that's a thing if
you want to check it out please do
thanks to Ryan Higa for injecting some
silly into the YouTube community take
yourself too seriously sometimes no
doubt about that also this is the thing
we're doing now it's a little tiny
French llama final toy and I think it's
cute you've never done toys like this
before it's seven dollars and you can
get it at dftba.com if there's a way for
me to apologize for ever rapping uh just
let me know in the comments John I'll
see you on Tuesday Tuesday not Wednesday
never Wednesday Tuesday what the heck